en el vídeo pasado estábamos hablando de
que teníamos una cuerda
y tomábamos el extremo izquierdo y lo
jala vamos hacia arriba hacia abajo y lo
regresamos a su posición de reposo ok
muy fácilmente pudimos haber tomado el
extremo derecho y moverlo a como
quisiéramos y sería lo mismo pero pues
tenemos que escoger uno de los dos lados
y escribimos el izquierdo
entonces tomamos el extremo izquierdo y
lo jala vamos hacia arriba hacia abajo y
lo regresa vamos y eso lo que provocaba
era una perturbación en la onda que se
veía más o menos así déjame borro aquí
lo que le sobra
y esta perturbación se propagaba a lo
largo del medio se movía un poco hacia
la derecha y si esperábamos suficiente
tiempo pues la cuerda terminaría
viéndose así y a esto es a lo que le
llamamos pulso a la perturbación que se
forma de mover la cuerda una vez como
queramos entonces si lo hacemos una sola
vez y dejamos de hacerlo lo que tenemos
es una onda de pulso recuerden que le
llamábamos onda a cualquier perturbación
que se propagara a lo largo de un medio
bueno pero en una onda podemos hacer
muchos pulsos uno después del otro y
como se vería la onda en ese caso pues
debería sí no
o sea si agarro el extremo izquierdo de
la cuerda y lo jaló hacia arriba y hacia
abajo y otra vez hacia arriba y hacia
abajo en intervalos de tiempo periódicos
con la misma longitud entonces se vería
así y bueno de la misma forma como lo
vimos en el vídeo pasado estas
perturbaciones se van a mover hacia la
derecha con cierta velocidad y lo que yo
quiero hacer en este vídeo es enfocarme
en este tipo de ondas que como pueden
imaginarse con todo eso que estamos
siguiendo un ciclo y estamos mandando
pulsos uno después de otro en ciertos
periodos de tiempo pues se llaman ondas
periódicas
ok estas ondas se forman para repetir el
mismo movimiento hacia arriba hacia
abajo
exactamente igual muchísimas veces pero
hoy tienen que ser exactamente el mismo
movimiento una vez después de otra en el
mismo periodo de tiempo y en este vídeo
yo quiero hablar de esas zonas y una de
las primeras cosas que nos podemos
preguntar de esas ondas es que tanto te
estás alejando de la posición de reposo
a ver qué les parece si pintamos la
posición de reposo esta es la posición
de reposo si se me fue un poco hecho de
calahonda pero estáis entonces lo
primero que nos estamos preguntando es
que tanto estoy jalando la cuerda hacia
arriba y por lo tanto como la
perturbación se está moviendo hacia la
derecha esa es la misma pregunta a qué
tanto mide esta distancia ya esto es
justo a lo que le llamamos amplitud
algunos marineros hablan acerca de la
altura de las olas y eso está muy
relacionado con la amplitud pero no es
exactamente la amplitud los marineros
generalmente están interesados en toda
esta distancia desde este punto que se
llama el valle de la ola hasta este
punto que se llama la cresta de la ola
porque pues como están en el mar las
ondas que a ellos les interesa estudiar
son las olas del mar y bueno obviamente
si tú estás en este punto de la ola pues
te interesa saber cuál es toda esta
distancia no nada más la distancia desde
el punto de reposo a ver entonces esto
es el valle
y esta es la cresta
y bueno este ejemplo de las olas del mar
es otro ejemplo de cómo no todas las
ondas son generadas por mí y moviendo la
cuerda hacia arriba y hacia abajo y de
como esta gráfica puede modelar puede
representar un montonal de cosas pero
bueno a ver la amplitud es tal cual la
distancia que hay de la posición de
reposo a la cresta y claro que esa no es
la única pregunta interesante también lo
pueden preguntar hoy en salman qué tan
rápido estás moviendo la cuerda entonces
ustedes llegan y me preguntan cuánto
tiempo te tardas en cada ciclo cuánto
tiempo te tardas en jalar la cuerda
hacia arriba hacia abajo y regresar a su
posición a ver vamos a escribirlo por
acá cuánto tiempo dura cada ciclo pues
resulta que justo justo a esa cantidad
es a lo que nosotros le llamamos período
o sea si yo me tardo dos segundos en
jalar la cuerda hacia arriba jalarla
hacia abajo y luego regresarla a su
posición de reposo
entonces me estoy tardando dos segundos
en cada ciclo y entonces mi periodo es
de dos segundos y bueno también hay una
pregunta muy relacionada con esta
pregunta que es la pregunta de cuántos
ciclos estoy haciendo por cada segundo y
bueno de hecho aquí en lugar de
preguntar cuánto tiempo dura cada ciclo
podríamos haber preguntado cuántos
segundos dura cada ciclo
entonces déjenme borrar esto y ponerle
cuántos segundos dura cada ciclo
cuando nos preguntan cuántos segundos
dura cada ciclo o sea cuál es el periodo
pues la respuesta va a ser algo del
estilo cinco segundos por cada ciclo
pero cuando nos preguntan cuántos ciclos
por segundo nos están preguntando algo
que es más o menos inverso a cuántos
segundos dura cada ciclo o sea no nos
están preguntando cuánto nos tardamos en
jalar la cuerda hacia arriba hacia abajo
y regresar que es el periodo sino que
nos están preguntando ok fíjate en
cierta cantidad de tiempo y dime cuántos
ciclos en esa cantidad de tiempo que es
más o menos lo inverso al periodo
entonces ya había cinco segundos por
ciclo cuantos ciclos podemos completar
en un segundo pues podemos completar uno
entre esto o sea podemos completar un
quinto de ciclo
en un segundo
ya esto cuántos ciclos podemos completar
un segundo le llamamos frecuencia
generalmente al periodo lo denotan por
una t mayúscula y a la frecuencia la
denotan por una f minúscula a ver otra
vez la frecuencia es dado un segundo
cuantas veces podemos subir bajar y
regresar a la posición de reposo y el
periodo es cuánto tiempo nos tardamos en
subir bajar y regresar entonces la
frecuencia y el periodo son inversos el
uno del otro y eso lo podemos escribir
como que el periodo es uno entre la
frecuencia o también lo podemos escribir
como que la frecuencia es 1 entre el
periodo
entonces si te digo que en un segundo yo
puedo hacer 10 ciclos lo que te estoy
diciendo es que la frecuencia es de 10
ciclos por segundo
ahora a esto de ciclos por segundo todo
el mundo le llama hertz y eso es algo
que seguro ya has escuchado la
frecuencia es de 10
hertz y por lo tanto el periodo es de 1
entre 10 segundos por ciclo lo cual
tiene todo el sentido del mundo no o sea
si en un segundo puedo hacer 10 ciclos
entonces tiene todo el sentido del mundo
que me tardé un décimo de segundos en
hacer un ciclo y otra cosa que seguro
nos queremos preguntar es qué tan rápido
se está propagando la onda como
empezamos del lado izquierdo como
estamos jalando al lado izquierdo se
arriba y hacia abajo pues nos
preguntamos qué tan rápido está
propagamos de la onda hacia la derecha
entonces ahora queremos hablar de
velocidad
y pues vamos a querer usar este espacio
entonces hay que borrar
y bueno para conocer la velocidad
necesitamos saber qué distancia recorrió
la onda después de un ciclo entonces
empezamos en nuestra posición de reposo
y después de un ciclo observamos dónde
quedó ese último punto de la posición de
reposo
esta distancia esta distancia es la
longitud de onda
y bueno no nos tenemos que fijar
forzosamente en los puntos de reposo
también podemos usar las crestas y
entonces la distancia que hay de una
cresta a la siguiente cresta esa también
es la longitud de onda y es exactamente
igual a ésta por qué pues porque de una
cresta a la otra transcurre todo el
ciclo o sea si este era nuestro punto
original y la onda después de un ciclo
se trasladó hasta acá entonces este es
nuestra longitud de onda o sea nuestro
ciclo pudo haber empezado acá y
trasladados hasta acá y si se fijan por
cada posición de este ciclo tenemos una
posición en este ciclo la única
diferencia es que pasamos este pedacito
de este ciclo a el final de este ciclo y
la longitud de onda sigue siendo la
misma por supuesto que también se puede
medir la longitud de onda de un valle al
otro y como ya hemos visto la longitud
de onda va a ser la misma
se puede poner desde cualquier punto en
medio del ciclo
esta longitud nos da la misma longitud
de onda ahora algo muy muy muy
importante es que cuando estemos
midiendo la longitud de onda tenemos que
escoger dos extremos que tengan digamos
exactamente la misma posición o sea todo
el ciclo se tiene que completar en esta
distancia entre este punto y este punto
se tiene que completar exactamente un
ciclo por ejemplo algo que estaría muy
mal sería medir la distancia desde este
punto a este punto y decir que la
longitud de onda es ésta por qué porque
aquí definitivamente no se está
completando un ciclo y este punto
digamos que no es el análogo a este y
aquí se ve muy claro porque por aquí la
onda está subiendo y aquí la onda está
bajando entonces aunque estén a la misma
altura para la onda no son el mismo
punto no representan el mismo punto del
ciclo a diferencia de éste
y este o sea de aquí a acá si se
completa todo un ciclo están a la misma
altura y además la onda va en la misma
dirección pero lo importante es que si
se completa todo el ciclo
entonces ya que vimos cómo calcular la
longitud de onda pues vamos a escribirlo
entonces la longitud de onda
qué tan lejos se traslada una onda
después de un periodo de tiempo y bueno
eso de un periodo de tiempo pues en
realidad lo pudimos haber escrito como
después de un ciclo entonces ya sabemos
que a distancia recorrió la onda y
además sabemos en cuánto tiempo la
recorrió y eso es justo lo que es el
periodo el tiempo que se tardó en
recorrer un ciclo y bueno tal vez
recuerden ustedes esto pero la velocidad
es igual a
la distancia
sobre el tiempo o sea la distancia que
recorre el objeto entre el tiempo que
tarda en recorrer esa distancia y bueno
cuando estamos hablando de ondas que es
igual la velocidad
pues aquí ya sabemos que recorre cierta
distancia en un ciclo y además ya
sabemos cuánto tiempo se tarda en
completar un ciclo entonces para un
ciclo ya tenemos cuánta distancia a
recorrer y cuánto tiempo se tarda en
recorrer esa distancia osea ya tenemos
la velocidad
entonces en el caso de las ondas la
velocidad es longitud de onda
es la distancia que recorre la onda en
un ciclo entre el tiempo que se tarda la
onda en completar un ciclo o sea el
periodo
y como no queremos tener que estar
escribiendo longitud de onda todo el
tiempo pues vamos a llamarle por una
letra así como le llamamos s a la
frecuencia y t al periodo pues
generalmente le llaman lambda a la
longitud de onda y vamos a usar esa
notación
entonces la velocidad es igual a lambda
sobre el periodo y el periodo este ahora
hace apenas unos minutos estábamos
hablando de que uno entre t es igual a
la frecuencia entonces la velocidad
además de ser longitud de onda entre
periodo como uno entre período es igual
a la frecuencia entonces también es
igual a longitud de onda por frecuencia
y bueno una vez que ya conocen todos
estos términos
entonces ya pueden resolver la mayoría
de los problemas sencillos que se van a
encontrar de ondas y bueno veamos un
ejemplo
digamos que tienes una onda que tiene
una velocidad de 100 metros por segundo
hacia la derecha
siempre que estemos hablando de
velocidad estamos hablando de rapidez y
de una dirección aunque muchísimas veces
se nos olvida hablar acerca de la
dirección pero bueno tienes una
velocidad de 100 metros por segundo
hacia la derecha y digamos que la onda
de la que estamos hablando tiene una
frecuencia de pues pongamos leer no sé
unos 20 ciclos por segundo o sea tiene
una frecuencia de 20 y hertz
y qué es lo que eso significa pues si
tuvieras una ventana por aquí que solo
te dejara ver este punto pues lo que
estarías viendo es que este punto se
mueve para abajo para arriba para abajo
para arriba y así así así así rapidísimo
y como se mueve a una frecuencia de 20
ciclos por segundo entonces tuberías a
este puntito moverse 20 veces para abajo
y para arriba eso es lo que significa
que la frecuencia sea de 20 y hertz
entonces ya nos dieron la velocidad y
nos dieron la frecuencia y ahora es
súper fácil calcular cuál es la longitud
de onda
a ver díganme cuál es la longitud de
onda
bueno vamos a escribirlo por acá no
tenemos una velocidad de 100 y de una
vez vamos a ponerle las unidades son 100
metros por segundo y la velocidad como
acabamos de ver es igual a la longitud
de onda por la frecuencia pero esta
frecuencia es igual a 20 ciclos
por segundo o sea 20 hertz y pues aquí
lo que queremos hacer es despejar la
lambda o sea despejar la longitud de
onda o sea que hay que dividir entre 20
ciclos por segundo de los dos lados 100
metros sobre segundo por 1 entre 20 y
luego uno entre ciclos entre segundos
pues nos queda segundos entre ciclos
o sea es un veinteavo de segundos por
ciclo
y eso es igual a nuestra longitud de
onda haber 100 entre 20 pues nos queda 5
y luego los segundos se van a cancelar
con los segundos y nos van a quedar
metros por ciclos metros por ciclo
o sea que nuestra longitud de onda es de
5 metros por ciclo 5 metros por ciclo ya
calculamos la longitud de onda
así es que siempre siempre que te den
dos de estas cantidades
ya sea velocidad de frecuencia o
velocidad y longitud de onda o
frecuencia y longitud de onda vas a
poder calcular la tercera pero qué me
dicen del periodo pues el periodo es 1
entre la frecuencia
entonces el periodo es un veinteavo
segundos por ciclo
y de la misma forma si te hubieran dado
el periodo y la velocidad tú hubieras
podido calcular cuál era la longitud de
onda bueno espero que los conceptos
hayan quedado claros y de una forma un
tanto intuitiva y espero que te sirva